Hay un concepto universal y muy antiguo que las palabras tienen poder,
que los hechizos existen, y que si pudiéramos pronunciar las palabras adecuadas,
entonces, ¡pum! Vendría una avalancha
y aniquilaría a los hobbits, ¿correcto? Entonces ésta es una idea muy atractiva
porque somos flojos, como el aprendiz de hechicero,
o el mejor programador de computadoras del mundo.
Y entonces, esta idea nos ha impulsado.
Amamos la idea de que las palabras, al ser pronunciadas --
sólo son poco más que información,
pero evocan una acción física
en el mundo real que nos ayuda a realizar un trabajo.
Y entonces, desde luego, con muchas computadoras programables
y robots alrededor, esto es algo fácil de imaginar.
¿Cuántos de ustedes saben de lo que estoy hablando?
Levanten su mano derecha. Bien. ¿Cuántos de ustedes
no saben de lo que estoy hablando? Levanten su mano izquierda. Bien.
Bueno, Eso es genial. Fue muy fácil.
Ustedes tienen computadoras muy inseguras,
Entonces, la cuestión es que este es un tipo distinto de hechizo.
Este es un programa hecho con ceros y unos.
Puede ser pronunciado en una computadora. Hace algo como esto.
Lo importante es que podemos escribir en un lenguaje de alto nivel.
Un mago de las computadoras puede escribir esto.
Que se puede compilar en esto --en ceros y unos--
y se puede pronunciar por una computadora.
Y eso es lo que hace a las computadoras poderosas:
estos lenguajes de alto nivel pueden compilarse.
Entonces, estoy aquí para decirles que no necesitan una computadora
para hacer un hechizo. De hecho, lo que pueden hacer
a nivel molecular es que si codifican información
-Codifican un hechizo o programa como moléculas-
entonces la física puede interpretar esa información directamente
y correr el programa. Eso es lo que ocurre en las proteínas.
Cuando esta secuencia de aminoácidos se pronuncia como átomos,
estas pequeñas letras son pegajosas entre ellas.
Se colapsa en una estructura tridimensional que los convierte
en una nanomáquina que realmente corta el ADN.
Y lo interesante es que si cambias la secuencia,
cambias la forma tridimensional.
Y en su lugar obtienes una "engrapadora" de ADN. Estos son los tipos de
programas moleculares que queremos ser capaces de escribir,
pero el problema es, que no sabemos el lenguaje de máquina
de las proteínas; no tenemos un compilador para proteínas.
Así que me uní al creciente grupo de personas que intentan hacer
hechizos moleculares usando ADN. Usamos ADN porque es más barato.
Es más fácil de manejar. Es algo que entendemos muy bien.
Lo entendemos tan bien, de hecho, que pensamos que podemos realmente escribir
lenguajes de programación para ADN y tener compiladores moleculares.
Entonces, pensamos que podemos hacerlo. Y mi primera pregunta al hacerlo
-o una de mis preguntas al hacerlo- era: ¿Cómo puedes hacer
una forma arbitraria o un patrón con ADN? Y decidí usar
algo como origami de ADN, donde tomas una hebra larga de ADN
y la doblas en la forma o patrón que quieras.
Aquí hay una figura. De hecho pasé como un año en mi casa,
en ropa interior, codificanto, como Linus [Torvalds], en la imagen anterior.
Y este programa toma la figura, arroja 250 secuencias de ADN.
Estas como secuencias de ADN son lo que doblarán la cadena larga
en la forma que queremos hacer. Así que envías un e-mail
con estas secuencias a una compañía, y lo que hace
-la compañía los pronuncia en un sintetizador de ADN
Es una máquina como del tamaño de una fotocopiadora. Y lo que ocurre es,
que toman tu e-mail y cada letra en tu e-mail
la reemplazan con un grupo de 30 átomos, uno para cada letra,
A, T, C y G en ADN. Los alinean en la secuencia correcta,
y luego te los envían de vuelta por paquetería.
Así obtienes 250 de estos por correo en pequeños tubos,
los mezclas, agregas un poco de agua con sal,
y luego agregas esta cadena larga de las que les hablé,
que robamos de un virus. Y lo que ocurre entonces es,
que calientas todo esto casi ebullendo. Lo enfrías
a temperatura ambiente, y mientras lo haces,
lo que ocurre es que las pequeñas cadenas, hacen lo siguiente:
cada una de ellas une la hebra larga en un lugar,
luego tiene una segunda mitad que se une a la hebra larga
en un lugar distante, y junta las dos partes de la hebra larga
para que se puedan unir.
Y entonces el efecto total de las 250 de estas hebras es que doblan
la hebra larga en la figura que buscabas;
Aproximando esa figura. Lo hacemos de verdad en tubos de ensayo.
En cada pequeña gota de agua obtienes 50 billones de estos chicos.
Puedes verlos con un microscopio y observarlos en una superficie.
Y lo mejor es que si cambias la secuencia
y cambias el hechizo, puedes cambiar la secuencia de los "ganchos"
Puedes hacer una molécula que sea como esto, y, saben,
le gusta estar con sus amigos.
Y muchos de ellos son bastante buenos.
Si cambias el hechizo otra vez, cambias la secuencia otra vez.
Obtienes triángulos de 130 nanómetros muy bonitos. Si lo haces nuevamente,
Puedes obtener patrones arbitrarios. Así en un rectángulo
puedes trazar patrones de norte y sur-américa, o las palabras "DNA."
Entonces eso es origami de ADN. Es una forma, hay muchas formas,
de lanzar hechizos moleculares usando ADN.
Lo que queremos hacer al final es aprender cómo programar
auto-ensamblaje para que podamos construir cualquier cosa, ¿correcto?
Queremos ser capaces de construir artefactos tecnológicos
que tal vez sean buenos para el mundo. Queremos aprender
cómo construir artefactos biológicos, como personas y ballenas y árboles.
Y si es el caso de que podemos alcanzar ese nivel de complejidad,
si nuestra habilidad para programar moléculas se vuelve así de buena,
entonces eso será realmente magia. Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)